how excited I was to meet you.
We're all so thrilled you're here.
- Oh, I'm thrilled to be there.
Hi, everybody. Hey.
What a great audience.
- [Drew] Thank you.
- Wow. My pleasure.
- So wait, okay, you
did the wacky wire game.
First of all, what is that?
- I don't even know.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
I was a law student at the time,
but we took a summer out and
it was a work exchange program
and all my buddies went
to work in the carnival.
And the next minute I'm
standing behind this wacky wire,
which is a wire that goes down like this
with a board behind and,
you have to take a loop,
metal loop, and take it round that loop
without touching the wire.
And if you touch it, it's over.
And if you don't touch it,
you win the biggest
teddy bear in the fair!
(audience cheers)
- It's sort of like Operation.
You know that game?
- Yes!
- Where like
if you touch the metal.
- That's exactly.
And the first person that came up to play
was a little kid and he just
walked up and he gave me $2.
And I'm like, I can't do this.
I just can't take people's money.
This is awful. I felt so bad.
Few days later I'm like,
"Hey kiddo, gimme that money.
Come on, gimme your money.
Biggest teddy bear in the fair."
- Well, okay, so how...
I didn't know this about you.
You were a fully fledged lawyer.
Like, a real lawyer.
- Like a lawyer.
Yeah, I was like a
lawyer, not just a lawyer.
- No, but that's actually not true.
- Oh, it's not.
- Well, it's mostly true.
I went through law school,
I got a honors law degree,
I got a diploma in legal practice.
I did my two years training
to become a lawyer.
- [Drew] And?
- Minus a week, and I
wasn't doing very well.
I hated what I was doing.
I wanna be an actor.
And about a week before
they sat me down, they said,
"This isn't really for you, is it?
This is not really what you wanna do?"
Kept going, and I became
the first trainee lawyer
in the history of the Scottish
legal system to be fired.
So I'm kinda proud of that.
But the next day I packed
my bags, moved to London,
and that was it.
I said this is in a way I've been released
to do what I wanna do.
- Okay, so I was looking at your IMDB,
but it was like a while before "300."
You know, you had been in
the business for a while,
but then when that movie hits,
oh my God, it hits so hard.
(audience cheering)
This Is such a major movie.
It's not only a box office success,
it's like a cult classic at the same time.
It's like, it's everything.
- Yeah, 'cause it fires
you up to, you know,
what are we gonna do?
- I don't know, but I love it!
- Yeah!
- And is it true that like, this is Sparta
was a line in the script,
but it's really you
that like gave it that energy and life?
What possessed?
- Well, yeah, because I was, you know,
we'd have that conversation
and go, you know,
this is madness, and I was, "Madness?"
This is Sparta." Boom.
I did a few takes like that, one a little.
(audience cheers)
I did one a little louder,
and then the scene was done
and they were moving on.
The guys are canning the camera away.
- [Drew] Oh God!
- I go, no, no, no, no, no!
Wait, wait, wait, wait
'cause I suddenly thought,
what about the wildness in these men?
There's a wildness and a surprise
and it's like, I can
have that conversation
and then you go, oh, this
is who they really are.
So they bring it back.
I went, "Madness?
This is Sparta!" Boom!
And they went cut, and I turn around
and everybody was laughing behind me
because it just seems so.
And I go over to the
director and I'm like,
that was too much, right?
He goes, "Yeah!
But it was awesome!
(audience applauds)
- Okay, you're in this new action thriller
that I'm obsessed with, "Plane."
We have a clip.
Let's take a look.
- There is no full rescue
team coming anytime, sir.
Not for the next 24 hours.
All right, we can't wait.
They're gonna come at us
with everything they've got,
and we're not gonna survive.
Now Danny and I managed to get the power
back up on the plane.
I know we have one chance, and that is me
flying us outta here on this thing.
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
(audience cheering)
- I didn't even see that clip.
- I luckily watched the clip.
I've seen the film.
Okay, so this film is
so juicy I have to say.
- Juicy is a good word.
- It really is.
It's like, it just, It gives you
all of that yummy stuff you crave
when you go to an action film.
Did you do pilot training for this?
- I did do pilot training.
I spent a lot of time in a simulator.
I had two of the coolest
pilots with me all the time.
- Really?
- Yeah, they trained me in the simulator.
So in the simulator, you
really feel like you're flying
and what you're looking
at digitally is so real.
You're watching cars, and the
405, I passed my old house,
I went under the Hollywood sign,
I'm taking a photos as I'm
flying the plane going,
look, this is me at the Hollywood sign
because a lot of the movie,
you're flying a, you know,
basically it's like a 737 over the ocean,
onto the island looking for a
place to land in the jungle,
and the river back out in the ocean back.
So that's what I was doing in LA.
I was flying over the 405, the 101
because if you're playing the pilot
you wanna immerse the
audience in this world.
And I feel like those
scenes, you really feel like
you're in that cockpit with
us going through the storm,
having to make the decisions that we make
because this guy is a hero, but he's not.
He's a regular guy.
It's like, what do these
situations pull outta you
when an ordinary person
suddenly finds himself
in these extraordinary situations?
And I love making those movies
where they're flesh and blood.
They make mistakes.
You know, he doesn't get it
right this guy, but he tries.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat bright music)